a CBS News investigation this summer
uncovered a hidden foreign workforce
building auto plants across the country
the first time this morning an American
business owner is speaking out about how
the practice hurts American workers Jim
Axelrod is here with how those concerns
are being ignored Jim good morning good
morning we found hundreds of Eastern
European workers on American
construction sites including factories
for BMW and Volvo now South Carolina's
business owners tell CBS News they are
being undercut by cheap foreign labor
and they've been trying to put a stop to
it for years it's good for the customers
Donna rau is the CEO of AEC a company
that builds and installs automation
equipment from its shop in Greenville
South Carolina just down the road from
dozens of major manufacturing plants
we're right in the middle of what should
be a very successful place for not only
us to be but for other automation
companies but Rao says jobs that could
be done by her 50 local employees
instead going to workers hailing from
half a world away our competition is
coming in from overseas from Poland
Romania Croatia Italy same work same
work same training same training and in
some ways we have better training
because we've been doing it longer just
a much lower cost much lower cost a CBS
News investigation this summer
discovered hundreds of men from Eastern
Europe working for subcontractors on
projects in Alabama and Michigan as well
as South Carolina what are you doing
here they are paid as little as $10 an
hour and brought to the US for six
months at a time
thanks to these visas which allow
foreigners to supervise work but not
actually do it themselves a loophole we
found being exploited at the expense of
American workers it's hard to describe
what it's like to sit with an employee
and tell them I have to lay you off I
don't have a job for you when you know
that other people are taking those jobs
now and
other south carolina's business
executives who decline to speak publicly
for fear of being blacklisted told us
they've made dozens of complaints like
these to state officials starting as far
back as 2013 and what have you heard we
don't want to be upsetting the larger
manufacturing companies that are coming
in if we make it hard for them they
won't come so it makes sense that a
German car coming would break ground in
Spartanburg South Carolina you can call
it home over the past decade
South Carolina has handed out hundreds
of millions of dollars in tax incentives
to lure foreign manufacturers to the
state in exchange they create permanent
American jobs but there are no
requirements the plants themselves must
be built by Americans the piece that
we're being left out of is during the
building of that plant that's the area
that an automation company lives in the
man who helps secure those deals is
South Carolina Secretary of Commerce
Bobby hid who worked at BMW for 17 years
multiple local business owners told us
they've complained about foreign workers
directly to his office he declined our
request for an interview I wonder if I
could ask you a couple of questions we
did they declined an interview sir why
don't you talk to us about this they say
the only thing about well they say they
don't have a level playing field here in
South Carolina well I don't know
anything about the jobs you're supposed
to go to Americans and South Carolinians
are going to Romanians and people from
the Czech Republic and Poland and Bosnia
is there merit to what they're saying
that there was only I think they were
complained to me if there was a problem
well so if we get in touch with your
communications director are you going to
set up an interview because she declined
our request not likely so did you ever
get an interview oh well we heard from
the communication director after I
attempt to talk to the secretary but it
was not exactly to schedule an interview
as for their part Volvo and BMW tell us
that it is actually their subcontractors
responsibility to ensure that their
employees are properly and legally
permitted to work in the United States
they didn't want to schedule an
interview what did they want
leave us alone Jim essentially I mean
you saw the door closed yes but it's one
of those moments where it's like where
is the elevate
believe me more than that elevator to
get there really good reporting on God
we followed up on the co2